[Music]
nice to meetcha bro I'm the new Robin
this is the dopest gig ever kicking
asses being famous driving the Batmobile
lets you drive the Batmobile
[Music]
everybody is Charlie happy Batman day I
totally did not expect them to drop
Jason Todd footage this soon after just
dropping those preview images so let's
break it down and there's also an
interview with Kevin Conroy because it's
Batman day so I'll play that clip in a
second and explain details about what's
going on with this DC streaming service
where all the apps are and how you can
watch if you're outside the United
States right now because this is a
limited rollout right now
all the original shows aren't premiering
til October 12th so because this is new
I'll do a giveaway for gift cards for
this DC service all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video the tone of their
scene here gives you a good idea of how
old Jason Todd is compared to Dick
Grayson so he obviously helps him out
there probably in Gotham because I can't
imagine that this Jason Todd is old
enough to be running around the United
States all by himself
maybe he's about the same age as Beast
Boy maybe a little bit older still very
very young but like I did that Red Hood
video yesterday not that far off from
dying coming back as Red Hood so well
cross our fingers on that never before
will you be so intent on waiting for a
character to die and then come back to
life save for like Jon Snow and Game of
Thrones but the series does jump around
to a lot of different cities so it's not
like all the episodes take place in
Gotham or they all take place in San
Francisco or they all take place
somewhere else I've only seen the first
few episodes because they haven't
released screeners for every single
episode so wherever this is from it's
not from the episodes that they've
released so I'm guessing it's from way
way down the line I do like a lot of the
energy that the young actor is bringing
to the character this is obviously
before they come to blows if you haven't
watched it yet Batman under the Red Hood
the animated movie is a really good
intro for the Red Hood character if
you're not a big comic book reader the
Boy Wonder are you kidding me edition
rocks come on old man we've got bad guys
who need chasing
you
this is the best that is currently
available on the DC streaming service
they have pretty much the entire bat
library of movies and TV shows that
encompasses everything going back to the
original Batman series I think they even
have the original Superman serials but
if you don't remember in that original
Red Hood animated movie Jensen Ackles
played Jason Todd what bothers you more
that your greatest failure has returned
from the grave or that I've become a
better Batman than you ruling through
intimidation and murder you're just
another criminal I'm with the city I've
already talked a little bit about their
relationship when they first meet
remember this is the first time that
they've ever met each other Dick Grayson
has no idea what Batman has been doing
since he left the bat family so to speak
although as far as I know within the
world of this series is just the two of
them I don't really know how they're
gonna invoke Barbara Gordon Batgirl or
if she's working as Oracle during the
course of the series we'll probably find
that out eventually there's a lot of
Easter eggs that give you an idea for
what people are doing all these
secondary characters just in terms of
the sheer quantity of big a-list
characters Titans is starting out much
bigger than the arrowverse shows but
just remember they're still focusing on
those four core characters so even
though a bunch of people will come and
go throughout the seasons and though
cycle in members of the roster like
Donna Troy is gonna be a much bigger
character during season two cyborg is
gonna become a character eventually most
of season 1 is dedicated to Robin
becoming Nightwing I know there's a lot
of rumors about like a post-credits
scene at the end of episode 12 where
everybody gets their new costumes but
also Raven learning who she is who her
father is about Trigon and what her
abilities are because when the series
picks up she doesn't have any idea
what's going on she just knows that
there's a darkness inside her and she
does some really messed-up stuff she
doesn't come right out of the gate
knowing how to control that but here's
that clip of Kevin Conroy talking about
Batman the Animated Series then I'll
talk about how to actually watch this DC
streaming service the cast was
incredible it all started in 92 and it
all kind of evolved slowly I didn't
really know what I was getting into I
just booked I was an actor that book did
I didn't know was gonna last for 27
years I didn't know who's gonna become
an iconic character so each day's
experience for me was a totally new
experience each week I think it can't
get better than this and then the next
week you would actually get better the
journey of playing Batman has been all
about its it's all about the tragedy of
his childhood and reliving that drama
that created him and that's been what's
been so challenging as an actor and
what's made it so much fun he's such a
complicated dark character because that
memory is always with them that's what
transformed him so much of his
psychology is about his parents and
about his youth you know actors they say
we are our instrument you are what you
bring your whole life experience is what
you bring a lot of my personal drama has
to do with my father and in a very
complicated relationship we had so
anytime a character is is touching that
tapping that experience it just Wells up
something in me that's very immediate
and Andre knows that she'd see it she'd
see me go through this during recording
since she'd always come into the room
and give me a hug she'd say you okay so
that was challenging and also because it
goes back into his childhood it goes
back into that drama of what made him
what he is and I think that's why fans
love him so much and why they relate so
much to him he's a damaged he's a
damaged hero and people love that about
him over the years I have had such
amazing experience with the fans that's
that's I go to Comic Cons a lot and
that's the reason the cool thing about
the service is is that the version of
Batman the Animated Series that they put
on it is the blu-ray remasters so it
looks and sounds way better than the old
DVD transfers for those of you that live
outside the United States and you're
asking how to watch all this stuff how
to get the episodes of Titans and Young
Justice and all that stuff when it rolls
out most of the people in my Twitter
feed have been saying that VPNs have
been working for them so you still have
to sign up for the service like you
would normally do but you can access
using a VPN but they did say back during
comic-con that they eventually plan on
rolling out international versions to
different countries like a version for
Canada a version for the UK so if you
don't want to wait you can actually sign
up for it now they do have a trial
period and if you sign up for a year
they're giving you three months free but
you don't get that if you don't sign up
for the whole year you can't sign up for
monthly though so what will happen is is
in a couple weeks at New York comic-con
Titans is gonna have its world premiere
they'll drop some more footage they'll
talk about the characters and what the
series is gonna be like some of the
other stuff that's coming to the DC
streaming service next year like Young
Justice that's what I'm allowed to post
my non-spoilery review and then Friday
October 12th is when Titans starts
rolling out episodes week to week so
will it be a Friday show but when they
release that next trailer I'll just do
another video and remind people about
what the schedule is going to be and we
can all figure out how we're gonna deal
with this new series because it is kind
of a new situation with the streaming
service but what'll happen is this I had
a chance to see the my hero academia 2
heroes movies so I'll do a non-spoilery
review of that later today so New
Avengers tomorrow there's a whole bunch
of stuff coming up click here for that
new Captain Marvel trailer announcement
and click here for that brand new flash
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight